et cette mobilisation nationale
également contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles l appel du collectif nous
toutes espèrent mobiliser dans les rues
partout en france à paris le rendez vous
était donné place de la république c'est
là qu'on retrouve notre reporter et
stéphane
hessel bonjour le cortège qui s'est donc
élancé
[Musique]
exactement à maera c'est une marée à
violette qui est encore en train de
progresser tout doucement vers la place
de la nation vous pouvez peut-être le
voir derrière moi sur ces images de
robin dubois et une manifestation à
l'appel du collectif nous tout alors ici
il s'agit non seulement de dénoncer les
violences sexuelles et sexistes mais
aussi d'interpeller les candidats à la
présidentielle à quelques mois de cette
échéance le collectif entend a dénoncé
le décalage entre les discours et la
réalité le collectif de tout pour qu'ils
aient les moyens déployés pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et les féminicides son aide dérisoire
il réclame plus de budget mais aussi
plus de mesures de prévention par
exemple car elle la réalité en france et
bien elle sait que depuis le début de
l'année 2020 payants sont une femme ont
été tués par leur conjoint plus
globalement ce sont 220 mille femmes qui
sont victimes de violences dans le pays
chaque année des chiffres inacceptable
ici vous proposera d'écouter celles à
qui nous avons pu parler
moi ce que j'aimerais bien qui c'est qui
est plus d'hommes aussi qu'on sera tous
ensemble pour parce que ça peut
bénéficier à tout le monde voilà mais
oui oui en effet sur tout d'abord pour
pour les droits de toutes ces femmes qui
sont discriminés que ce soit au travail
que ce soit dans leur couple dans leur
vie intime partout dans l'espace public
aussi c'est pour la présidentielle mais
pas seulement c'est on est dans le cadre
de la semaine et de la journée
internationale contre les violences
faites aux femmes le 25 novembre
c'est pour dire qu'il faut que ça cesse
que c'est pas normal que les femmes se
trouve victime comme elles le sont
aujourd'hui c'est aussi une question
d'éducation
et
il faut que dans les écoles on met en
place des travaux ça se fait d'ailleurs
avec les enseignants sur l'égalité
filles garçons sur le respect mutuel
pour qu'on n'en cesse avec ses pains
incontournable ces violences envers les
femmes c'est une question de culture et
voilà donc il faut continuer
voilà et noter que cette manifestation
intervient est cinq jours avant la
journée internationale de lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
merci estelle pour toutes ces précisions